warning the following video contains
spoilers is a freaking reaction video
what do you expect Hitler won World War
two fantastic starts workplace hazards
causing injuries call injury laws for
you I'm sure this is 100 percent
accurate size perspective run Forrest
run
that doesn't seem physically possible oh
wait I'm using my brain again of course
it's called a Goku uniform I'm a you
start inmate you start him come at me
bro this arena seems unnecessarily large
how did I get up here
that's a girl oh yeah kill the kill baby
what the [ __ ] does that even mean who
eats lemons like that first love does
not taste like lemons you [ __ ] lemon
child abuse for the wind that's red
highlight look stupidly out of place
epic flying text looks like he got
killed or killed sir while a giant
floating text in the classroom I think
she's just a personification of this
entire anime so the school is run as the
fascist society with a strong rule and
the weak get oppressed thanks Obama I
mean Hitler my scissor is the scissor
that will pierce the heavens just watch
me run with them in the hallways huh
okay brick [ __ ] kpop nerd haha
they're pretending to have a plot I'm
just here for the ladies in Soviet
Russia school uniform relay of you and
just when I thought anime couldn't get
any weirder actually no one can see your
panties wait how is that possible epic
entrance baby my drill is the drill that
will wake
what the boner I I don't I don't even
she must have really small nipples what
the hell are you talking about you're
not wearing anything is he just talking
about how he's gonna fist her now more
drills I see what you're doing cuz her
butt have cleavage or desert cleavage
have but what [ __ ] Armor you're not
wearing anything Catering yoga Ruiz this
is the stupidest thing I've ever seen
shut up brain I think that was the sound
of my brain cells imploding from
awesomeness and that's my friends is how
you kick someone's ass 'la ass
next time on kill the kill so sexy I'm
gonna faint
so sexy I'm gonna faint so sexy I'm
gonna faint enemy of the Year hey guys
get go care I sorry I can't be on camera
today anyway hope you enjoyed the video
and if you want to see more of kill to
kill then it's available on crunchyroll
so you can also go to crunchy like on
sassy anime zone for three months or
premium membership now before you ask
yes I am doing a Titan review though
it's been delayed a bit since I've
learned all my time this last month
working on Ava Bridge 4.0 which I highly
suggest you watch since it's the most
work I've put into a single video you
can also find some my other reactions
and reviews here and you can follow me
on Facebook and Twitter in the
description below so I'm gonna get
working on the Titan review but until
then I'll see you all next time